ننتقل الى كارمن كارمن كيف بدل وضع واخر
التطورات في مناطق سيطره الانفصاليين
الموالين لروسيا
[موسيقى]
نعم السهام بطبيعه الحال كما تشاهدون هذا
احد المنازل المدمره خلفي بالقصف
الاوكراني هذا القصف الذي يستمر طيله
النهار على دانياسك اليوم تم الحديث عن
مقتل امراه واصابه شخصين في هذا القصف
الاوكراني والممثلي لجمهوريه
تحدثت عن قيام القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف
دانيت اكثر من 60 مره ب 350 قذيفه من
عيارات متعدده قالت الممثلين ايضا ان هذا
القصف استهدف مباني سكنيه دمر عددا من
المباني السكنيه 15 مبنى وايضا دمر مدرسه
في هذه المنطقه ايضا بالتوازي مع ما يجري
في دانياس هناك حديث اليوم العنوان الاول
الذي يتصدر كل ما له علاقه بالميدان
المرتبط بصاروخ كنترول وما اعلنته وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يوم امس عن
منظومه باتريوت الامريكيه المضاده
للطائرات تكشف التفاصيل جديده تحدث عنها
وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه الذي قاله ان
العدد الذي تحدثت عنه اوكرانيا وهو سته
صواريخ غير صحيح وقال ان غالبا ما تقوم
بتضخيم اعداد هذه الصواريخ التي تستخدمها
روسيا في هجوماتها بنحو ثلاث مرات وقال
وهذه معلومه مهمه جدا تحدث عنها مرتبطه
بمنظومه الامريكيه قال ان هذه المنظومه
غالبا ودائما ما تخطئ الصواريخ من نوع
كنجال الفرد صوتي والذي تتجاوز سرعته سرعه
الصوت باربع مرات ايضا بالتوازي مع هذا
الاعلان من قبل وزير الدفاع الروسي كانت
هناك معلومات ومصادر تحدثت لوكاله نوفوستي
الروسيه تحدثت ووصفت مجارى فيكياف بالكمين
الجوي لمنظومه تحدثت عن تفاصيل ايضا حول
ما جرى في تلك الليله قالت ان منظومه
باتريوت غير قادره على اعتراض صواريخ مثل
صواريخ كنجال لانها غير قادره نظرا لسرعه
هذا الصاروخ الكبير على تحضير الذخيره
والتعامل مع هذا الصاروخ هذا العنوان
الاساس اليوم بالنسبه لروسيا وكثير من
المواقع وكثير من وسائل الاعلام المحليه
الروسيه تتناقل ما قاله مسؤول امريكي لسى
حول احتمال كبير ان تكون منظومه باتريوت
الامريكيه قد حصل وقد لحق بها التلف جراء
هذا الهجوم الروسي ايضا بالتوازي مع ذلك
هناك معركه هناك معركه باكموت القوات
القوات فاجنر تتحدث عن مزيد من التقدم في
تلك الجبهه بالتحديد شكرا لك يا كارمن جو
خضار كنت معنا من